and you want to try the butter type what
do you think guys it's the winner so
every time we go on a trip with Hayden
we have a rule what's the rule it's a
highlight earning this trip
[Music]
hello hello hello
we are all set for day two of our West
Coast adventure Haven woke up super
early we're still jet lag so we got up
around 6:30 I didn't mess it up I just
there is a time difference woke up at
6:30
it's look at this beautiful speeds are
empty is the main street vancouver this
ends because it's 8:00 something on the
saturday morning we're gonna explore i'm
gonna get coffee first and a hot
chocolate for this man and then hit the
streets of Vancouver
so everybody in the family wants to have
a Tim Horton's in the morning all right
Tim Hortons for me and Hayden in
Starbucks for Nina
[Music]
Nina changed her mind she wanted a
coffee here how can we change in my Nina
it's much work we would have done it
like you tomorrow we're gonna make here
we go
okay good news they ran out of Nina's
french vanilla so you usually have to go
to Starbucks
[Music]
first stop Granville Island it's one of
my favorite places to go in Vancouver is
this little island well yes the ferry
will take a cigarette of our Island they
have lots of artisans there selling some
awesome food that they make stones all
right so we're gonna get on the ferry
and make way
[Music]
are you ready to get on the ferry yeah
that's our boat the yellow on here comes
[Music]
alright there it is Granville Island
public market that's where we're going
[Music]
Nina's getting hungry make some muscles
[Music]
muscles of white sighs look at this guy
[Music]
matcha green-tea fudge we might have to
come back here this we're gonna get
something here everybody picked
something on with the chair all right
time to eat butter quest sound oh look
at Nina trying to organize it
good job Nina and panel shoved a lot how
is it it's good
Mimi's eating - where's the thumb going
up alright okay how we feeling family
we're gonna go get this one some
best soup on the island
stock market soup all right let's get
Nina some soup best soup on the island
Nina what are you gonna have maybe tried
two different ones we could share you
know how you like the sample okay sad
news we're too early they don't do
breakfast soon very sad next up is
Laureles fine foods everything here is
supposed to be yummy that's ever
something all right and you want to try
the butter tart
[Laughter]
[Music]
here comes the sausage roll okay load it
up
grab a bite world's best sausage roll
about to get destroyed
[Music]
look at that look at that goo Venus look
at the goo so good
Lena's slept a lot last night what did
you do is that a lot all right good
everybody's happy on this trip so far
Nina wants to try the smoked salmon
jerky so we're gonna get stumped
nice yeah I'll try Hayden wants to try
is it good no it's okay Nina liked it
[Music]
Hayden is our official tour guide right
now in Granville Island
what's next captain okay okay all right
[Music]
okay
oh that sounds that you're saying let's
do it
[Music]
kids entrance Hayden kids entrance all
right Nina go nothing nobody's doing for
the kids
Oh Nina's gonna go through the kids and
[ __ ] gun inna you barely got the duck
it's a pig the air pig is sleeping pig
nice those Hayden
what are you there ha ha ha nice I like
that
what do you think guys it's a winner
[Music]
so every time we go on a trip with
Hayden we have a rule what's the rule
hey till to get one thing so he's
decided this is the one thing that he
wants that means no more asking for
stuff very exciting he's got this one
thing
okay good news guys we've burned so much
time hanging around Granville Island
that it's almost 11:00 and we can go
super Nina
[Music]
we are back to get Nina her soup soup
time here she comes she got herself two
small soups all right and some bread
what kind of soup that you get okay okay
yum lovely I'm gonna build what I'm
trying to say love it and yum this is
what we came here for the best soup in
Vancouver all right Nina
yummy thumbs up alright try the other
one
Nina loves soup she got her soup all day
we got her soup I'm glad we stayed at
the highlighted in this trip Hayden's
gonna go buy a hot dog by himself you
nervous no all right maybe but
definitely nervous okay go he's all
grown up Tina he's all grown up gonna
order by himself he did it alright let's
try some of that hot dog oh wait
[Music]
okay it's dessert time Hayden got a
smartie cookie and I got a Nanaimo bar
because Nanaimo is in British Columbia
so I might as well have a Nanaimo bar
from British Columbia okay try your
cookie yeah thumbs up be on thumbs up
alright nice okay nice and now I'm gonna
eat mine
alright Granville Island done what do we
think guys I love a love grandpa Ireland
lots of great little shops are designs
some cool food but now we're going to
head back to Vancouver over there and go
explore the city
[Music]
the hot dog with mustard
Porcha Stan there what do you think up
here mister
the famous steam clock I said everybody
was waiting for